previously on TV sins people of King's
Landing did not choose the false King
Joffrey Baratheon
vote for Kings two minutes of opening
credits including this harpy statue
squatting literally spread-eagle harpies
man I would never sit in this show again
if Jamie's hand would pull an evil dead
to idle hands right about now and
demonically kick the get out of vanilla
sky and his crew you and your sister go
in for Kingslayer considering how many
people seem to know already that Jaime
is being a sister I have to wonder if
attempting to murder bran was really
necessary
can't say that I've ever seen a man
drink horse piss that fast why are they
keeping horse piss it seems like a lot
of risk for a very little reward to
capture it man there's so much punching
and kicking here it might as well be an
ending to an MCU movie before all this I
was going to tell you the story of how
it still with as much out of the inn
depravity that this show chooses to
focus on the fate of varus's
unmentionables is by far the strangest
continued storyline in the first two
seasons and changed why is various
washing his hands right now sure he's
been messing with this big box of
vengeance but he's about to go take the
lid off again what do you wait until the
job was done to clean up already just
need something to do during a speechify
so Tyrion walked it at dr. Farris just
as Varys was about to reveal he had
captured the man who had taken his
livelihood oh well I'm not sure if that
is a coincidence or just being
ridiculous but it's sympathy also
considering there are holes in this box
and Tyrion is almost face level to them
was there any way he wouldn't have heard
seen or even smelled that there was a
human being in here before now so easy
to protect him now a good friend crusty
who's that again
Prester seriously trying to remember all
the characters on this show is like
trying to name all the state capitals in
alphabetical order sure you know that
there are some people who can do it but
you're just as sure that you don't want
to be one of those people whoa take a
chill pill girl you're already shushing
that baby long before Sammy stomp step
came around so don't blame him because
you can't keep your brother's son quiet
monopolies starting family fights even
in Westeros world you have to go off to
him how you know how since he hasn't
been able to
after quite a while and the non-dream
world why don't you quit being a dick
and be a little more helpful nightmare
on Love Actually Street what the hell is
up with brands clothing choices I don't
care if it is a dream there's no
reasoning with the weird shoulder chaps
strap on thing discount Jonathan Taylor
Thomas he has time for this
shipboard inventory inventory you just
subtracted a full syllable from the word
inventory and I can't decide if Game of
Thrones is doing research on old
pronunciations or just leaving errors
for the hell of it you can read Wrath
for a woman in your profession that's
sex worker issed I'm missing something
obvious you're about to point out well
that is my job
friar Kendall two featherbeds he's
bringing two featherbeds for the cabin
none done although considering how much
of a particular ass Littlefinger is
couldn't he just want two beds for
himself or maybe he's bringing a
companion along for the lonely nights at
sea maybe it's a lot but the way people
jump to conclusions in this show or one
thing the fact that they're always right
is no dick Ulis any predictable tragedy
hunting and drinking don't mix note to
self cancel all that wine I ordered for
the Safari I'm taking this fall I'll
just double up on cocaine seems to work
for the sons of super powerful people Oh
finally Marjorie will be the one to show
Joffrey how to be a good King and their
love will be an example for all the
years to come this show has let me down
before but I can just feel it this time
everything's coming together perfectly
beyond sure it's pretty light on his
feet for a guy it was only a few days
out from having giant screws drilled
into him I would think jumping and
running would feel like torture maybe
Tom barely Ramsay saw his shadow this
morning so we can expect six more weeks
of great joy torture Oh tis a beautiful
day Littlefinger is one of the most
dangerous men in Westeros you couldn't
even stop a Maze Runner
his name was Bannen damn man even though
he can't get the Hulk to come out
there's no reason to kill Bruce chant
commercials I know as much as ended role
commercials multiplier never meet a man
with 99 sons I hear if you take one down
and pass it around there's only 98 man
you could fill an entire Game of Thrones
episode with the amount of empty threats
in this series Brotherhood without
banners will hunt you down surprisingly
Brotherhood without banners was also the
name of my steampunk thrash hip hop band
in Community College because that tends
to happen a lot in Westeros with no
consequences except vigilante justice
[Applause]
meanwhile back on the only storyline we
currently give up even if the writers
don't seem to understand this disparage
these Almighty God Reese's booze diaries
caused our character acts ignorant of
what is being said behind their back but
actually spoke the language the whole
time and now uses that to their
advantage cliche I mean it's a badass
use of the cliche for sure but a cliche
nonetheless
dracarys
[Laughter]
this is flaming black one but your
mother informs me that you have a
girlfriend is there anything I can help
you he burned my parts in a brazier the
flames turned blue and I heard a voice
answer his call yes it's true
this man has known the corpus delicti
well I'm not particularly good be
stabbed strangled riddled with bullets
mutilated beyond recognition yep
what happens when the non-existent bumps
against the decrepit we have tried
grinding our mouths together out of
sheer boredom no sensation at all
[Music]